[Music]
dan's in kansas city hi dan welcome to
the ramsay show
well uh dave um
i am in a quandary okay uh
my wife and i married each other um
that's always a good thing to do
[Laughter]
excellent yeah excellent yes yes
thank you very much
we got married uh it'll be two years in
july and both of us have never been
married before but we had dated a long
time
um
since then we've been looking for a home
here and these prices have just gotten
insane
and
what we're having a major disagreement
about
and i mean a major disagreement about is
how to pay for this
i
uh
she said that when we got married now
this is a conversation that
i don't remember all the particular
details but she said that our original
plan was that she met or sells her house
i sell mine of which i already have and
i moved in with her in her place which
already has a hundred thousand dollars
worth of debt i married a hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt too
so
so she also says that we agreed when
before we got married that i would sell
my farm property
which is a quarter section out in
western kansas
um
that's been in family hands for 130
years now i don't exactly remember that
part of the conversation
but
i know that
when we sell that it's going to involve
capital gains taxes pretty substantial
ones my accountant says somewhere
between
oh 40 to 50 000
combined federal and state
so i propose to my wife this
that we keep the property
still buy a house because we can
we can cash flow
uh with the wheat sales about another
five six hundred dollars worth of
payments above and beyond of what we do
now
then we take the milo money
and we bank that for the next five years
which is when i plan to retire
and then we'll have at least that money
to pay most if not all
of these capital gains taxes
and then
we sell the property at that point and
retire the mortgage she says no sell it
now
and
you know then buy something cash
what do you think
so i'm hearing that either way the
property is sold it's just a matter of
now or five years from now
well
unless we can find a way or buy a
property that we can
that we can because she's saying let's
stop a second stop saying because
yeah this property you know you outlined
a very emotional
thing that's been in your family for 130
some odd years
130 yeah yeah so
you know um
oh
math aside
and even marital arguments aside
um
are you
gonna sell this property ever
well at some point because she has no
children and i have no children we've
never been married before and we have no
family
uh really i know that enters into it
yeah i mean well
it's going to leave the family you're
saying it's going to leave the family
when you die anyway
yes okay
so why not go ahead and enjoy
the fruits of some of it now what's it
worth if you sold it now
around 300. okay
all right and what's wrong with your
wife's current house as a place for
y'all just to stay
well
it's
it's a it's a two-bedroom townhouse
and um
it has one bath and and i've shared
i love my wife dearly that i've shared a
bath with her for almost two years and
i've not enjoyed the process okay so uh
so you guys what's the town house worth
ten house is worth about 180 190.
and with her um
with all the
we've had our
what is it is anything owed on it a
hundred thousand on it about a hundred
thousand yeah okay and so it's going to
clear about 80 and you've got about 300
over there and if you've got money left
over from the sale of your house also
110. okay
all right and so
you could buy a 200 000 property and pay
cash for it
we could but you can't get
really much in kansas city particularly
in johnson county where we live
you can't get much
for 200 let me flip this around what's
the alternative
you've created this what i would say is
a highly complex and i moved here from a
farming community a complex the the
grains have to hit has to rain right
we've got to get the subsidy in you've
laid out a complex matrix for five years
from now we could x y and z
yeah
that's in gymnastics life's a lot
simpler just know it now yeah
and a capital gain sounds like a
distraction to me
if if i didn't have all this other stuff
in this conversation i would tell you to
sell the property now pay the capital
gains sell the townhouse
and go buy a property that both of you
love now what's bothering me about that
is that the two of you after two years
can't to two old dogs
trying to learn new tricks working
together is tougher
than than two young pups doing that and
so
um
i i'm a whole lot i'm 90 concerned in
this conversation about the fact that
you two can't resolve this argument and
i'm only ten percent concerned with how
you resolve it
yeah
um
i mean to the point that she's even
saying you said things you don't
remember saying
that's weird
well um
she's a pretty powerful personality and
there are times during our long
relationship dating and married
that i have found it um
more
and i might have agreed to that i don't
i remember you what you're saying is you
caved
well i have found
that that sometimes it's better
or at least in the short term it's
better
than to keep
keep trying to re resolve the issue okay
that's my problem
okay
john help me here yes
my problem is i don't give a rip if you
sell the farm or not but the problem is
if you saw the farmer go do exactly what
she wants this is going to come up again
or if you lie to her in order to get
through a conversation all you're doing
is kicking the can down the road for a
larger explosion when it happens
and now you've drawn lines and the part
that you you've drawn battle lines i've
got my plan well she's got her plan
and
man this just doesn't end well it ends
unnecessarily bad particularly if both
of your plans end up with sell on the
farm
and so i would love to see you circle
back to her and say all right
so i've never done this before i've
never had a marital marital spat like
this before with 130 year old property
i'm asking for a mulligan can we start
the conversation anew
what do we want to look at you're
talking about she brought into debt and
i'm married y'all are all on the same
page you're just having to practice
doing life together after a long time of
not having to do life together expect
there to be stumbles be curious about
them don't get angry and frustrated
about them and always circle back and
say hey we need to do this one over
again and this is when you'll need to do
over again because what you're fighting
about is do we want to have a pretty
nice house for the rest of our life just
to ride or die with until this thing's
over which could be a lot of fun but if
you get bogged up in the mechanics of
how we're going to get there man then
you're just going to get bogged up
my wife
i caved and she held me to it
and i sold 130 130 year old family
property when i didn't want to just to
make her happy in this house then the
first time she whines about the
wallpaper you're going to go bananas
you're going to burn the house down out
of spite i might know somebody that did
this so i'm just telling you okay
i i'm i i've got this friend right so
named rave damsey
[Laughter]
yeah so you guys need to work on the
relationship part of this and then the
actual mechanics of how to do the deal
will be a whole lot easier
that's what's scaring john and i we're
looking at each other while you're
telling all this